with covet 19 testing becoming routine
there's an innovation that promises to
make it easier a breath test that's
coming soon to a doctor's office near
you if you live or spend time in the
united states the food and drug
administration has okayed the test for
emergency use accepting the developer
inspect ir's test results that show it's
more accurate than rapid tests and it's
purported to analyze and show results
green means negative in about three
minutes it's in a word pretty cool
canadian doctors like epidemiologist
rawat dionandin are intrigued by a test
that's non-invasive and might reduce
transmission rates in key settings so
imagine in front of a daycare center or
a school or a long-term care center or
someone walks in they breathe into the
device the technician looks at it for
about three minutes and says yes you can
come through or you can't come through
there are questions about cost which
neither the fda nor inspect ir is
advertising the company told global news
it's not releasing its pricing model at
this time
also unclear is what level of training
is required for a technician to operate
the testing machine
and there's a trade-off for that speed
and convenience breath tests aren't
really great at allowing us to get
details on the variant itself it doesn't
allow us to sequence
the actual
so all it says is yes no
and that's not super helpful if we're
trying to figure out where virus is and
how it's changing either dr barrett
considers the breath test a potential
niche system for covert testing not a
game changer she says anything credible
that promotes covet 19 testing is worth
exploring
health canada says it has not yet
received an application for the breath
test ross lord global news